artificial intelligence machine learning
and deep learning represent the
evolution of computer science towards
creating intelligent systems AI is the
broader concept striving to build
machines capable of human-like
intelligence ml is a subset of AI
emphasizing algorithms that learn from
data to make predictions or decisions DL
in turn is a specialized branch of ml
that employs deep neural networks to
model complex patterns imagine an AI
powered Voice Assistant like Apple Siri
it utilizes ml to understand and respond
to user queries learning from
interactions over time deep learning
comes into play when CI recognizes
speech patterns or interprets natural
language using neural networks to
process intricate features the better it
becomes at understanding diverse accents
or refining responses exemplifying The
Continuous learning inherent in these
Technologies AI seeks to emulate human
intelligence ml harness data for
Learning and DL employees deep neural
networks for intricate task the
integration of these Technologies
manifest in everyday applications
transforming how we interact with and
benefit from intelligent systems here's
a quick info for you before moving on to
the topic if you want to switch careers
with a ml then try G simply learns
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning from per University in
collaboration with IBM this course
teaches in demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning generative
AI promt engineering jat GPT and many
more so don't forget to check out the
course link from the description box and
pin comment so without any further Ado
let's get started so let's start with
what is artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence imparts data and
humanlike intelligence to machines
aiming to create autonomous systems that
can emulate human behavior these
machines learn and solve problems
simulating natural intelligence to
tackle complex task consider an
illustration of an AI driven product the
Amazon Eco the Amazon ECO stands as a
smarter speaker employing Amazon's
virtual assistant AI technology known as
Alexa this technology enables voice
interaction allowing the device to play
music set alarms present audio books and
provide upto-date information on topics
like news weather Sports and traffic
reports Etc let's move forward and see
what is machine learning machine
learning is a subset of artificial
intelligence that focuses on developing
algorithms and models capable of
learning and making predictions or
decisions without being explicitly
programmed ml systems leverage data to
recognize patterns adapt and improve
their performance over time there are
several types of machine learning number
one supervised learning the algorithm is
trained on a label data set where each
input is associated with the
corresponding output number two comes is
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning deals with unlabelled data to
find inherent patterns or structures
within the information and then comes
the reinforcement learning this type
involves training agents to make
sequences of decisions by interacting
with an environment and then comes
semi-supervised learning semi-supervised
learning combines supervised and
unsupervised learning elements typically
using a small amount of labeled data and
a larger pool of unlabeled data let us
move forward and see what deep learning
is deep learning a branch of machine
learning focuses on algorithms inspired
by the human brain structure and
functionality it excels in processing
vast amounts of both structured and
unstructured data at the heart of deep
learning are artificial neural networks
empowering machines to make decisions
the key distinction between deep
learning and machine learning lies in
data presentation machine learning
algorithms typically demand structured
data while deep learning networks
operate through multiple layers of
artificial neural networks allowing them
to handle diverse data formats so let's
start with the difference between
artificial intelligence machine learning
and deep learning and this will show in
a tabular form so starting with the
definition so Definition of artificial
intelligence so broad field of machine
learning or creating machines with
intelligent behavior is artificial
intelligence and when we talk about
machine learning is the subset of AI
focusing on algorithms learning from
data and then comes the Deep learning
that is specialized subset of ml using
deep neural networks and now we'll see
the difference with the learning
approach between all these three so in
learning approach artificial
intelligence can include rule-based
systems expert system and more and in
machine learning it learns from data
patterns without explicit programming
and then comes the deep learning where
it learns hierarchical representation
using neural networks and if we talk
about scope it encompasses various
techniques Beyond learning from data and
in machine learning it primarily focus
on learning patterns from data and then
the Deep learning it specifically
utilizes deep neural networks for
complex task and now we'll move to the
next difference and we'll start with an
example so in artificial intelligence
the example is autonomous vehicles chat
boards or expert systems and for machine
learning it spam filters recommendation
systems image recognition and in deep
learning it is image and speech
recognition natural language processing
and now we'll see the difference for the
data requirements so it depends on the
specific application and problem solving
approach and in machine learning it
requires labeled or unlabelled data or
training and for the Deep learning it
relies on large amounts of labeled data
for training deep networks and now for
the complexity artificial intelligence
addresses a wide of task including those
Beyond ML and in machine learning it
deals with moderate to complex task
depending on algorithms and for the Deep
planning it is well suited for intricate
task often requiring substantial
computational resources and now see the
flexibility so for the artificial
intelligence it can be rule based
evolving and adaptive and for the
machine learning the flexibility adapts
to patterns and the changes in data and
for the Deep learning it adapts to
hierarchical presentations and diverse
data
types and then comes the training
process so in artificial intelligence
training process varies based on
specific AI techniques used and in
machine learning training involves
feeding data and adjusting model
parameters and in deep learning training
involves optimizing neural weights and
structures and now we'll talk about the
applications between all these three
terms that is AIML and deep learning so
for artificial intelligence the
applications are robotics natural
language processing game playing and for
machine learning it's Predictive
Analytics fraud detection and Healthcare
Diagnostic and for the Deep learning
that is image recognition speech
synthesis and language translation and
with that guys we have come to the end
of this video if you have any questions
related to this video please ask them in
the comment section below and our team
of experts will be happy to help you as
soon as possible thank you and keep
learning and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here